on your back go get up shoo go back up
and shoot quick they're shooting at you
come on get back up shoot
prefers the fear goes it's super real I
mean I think about it more you hear
about these active shootings at least
once a week there was our land oh and
you do think what would I do in a
situation if I was trapped and about
them at the hundred people and someone
came in with with the gun at least at
this class I feel the confidence that at
least maybe I'd try something the reason
I'm doing this is protect myself my
family my house you know my kids get up
get up
fix your feet fix your arms fix
everything get on your original target
keep shooting keep shooting keep
shooting
sure
everyone do that go don't move it's not
marksmanship our goal here guys
isn't data bullseye put a lot of rounds
in the center of the cavity as quickly
as possible just as a guy goes down
afterwards you can decide you want to
leave you want to run up to him you
wanna grab his gun essential to have an
active shooter class probably it's just
the reality of our world there's urban
terrorism reserve in situations mass
shootings things happening overseas it's
not so much fear for me but I think
anyone who is potentially an amazing
situation to operate a handgun should
know how to use it quickly and
effectively and safely